thank you for joining us America we're
glad you're here josh is with us in Fort
Wayne Indiana Josh welcome to Dave
Ramsey show better than I deserve how
can I help
I can't hear you you need to talk
directly into your phone please can you
hear me better now yes sir thank you all
right about that I read your bus a
couple months ago a friend of Mines and
doing the baby steps for a while now and
we bought it for me and I'm totally on
board with the plan and we started doing
the budget or doing pretty good with
that but I'm having a hard time talking
to my fiance about all the baby steps
and why we do this why we supposed to do
some of the things we do I'll give you
an example she's almost done paying off
her car good but but she's almost a
hundred thousand miles on her car and
she's of the opinion that wants the cars
paid off she's gonna go get another car
and trade that in and start a whole new
low so I'm not sure how to get my point
across on how this is supposed to work
without sounding mean or like I'm
telling her this is what we're going to
do because I know able to do this
together and do something in order to
make our moldboard wants to get married
all right well you don't need to do
money together until you're married that
would be a bad yeah but we need to
discuss it we need to discuss it and so
when are you getting married
good okay fine
all right well here's how a conversation
could sound you could sit down and say
you know I've been gotten kind of
interested in this stuff since so-and-so
gave me a copy of this book and the more
I read about it and the more I
understand I found out that the number
one thing that couples fight about and
the number one cause of divorce is money
money fights and money problems are the
number one sticking point in marriage
and so if we found out that the number
one cause of anything was
we would deal with X right right if it
was Blue Sox we would avoid Blue Sox you
know I mean it's that simple whatever it
is we would just say if that if the
number one cause of having the flu is
wearing blue socks that's obviously
absurd but you would quit wearing blue
socks right so right you know you might
sit down and just say based on the idea
that it's the number one problem in
marriage that means you and I should
work on this we should work on this
really really hard because if you kill
the number one killer of marriages your
marriage has got a really good shot and
so I want to make sure that our marriage
because I love you I want to make sure
our marriages is starting off right and
also has the foundation to go and that
means we've got to get this money stuff
figured out together and so you know I
read this book won't you read this book
and let's talk about it together that's
the problem here I tried to get her to
read the book she's not not much of her
we didn't do it the way I just said well
that's your right I didn't you just said
hey read this book I did that's correct
yeah you're about as subtle as a brick
through a window it doesn't work we're
gonna have to try a little more a little
more honey on the bread so you know my
point is baby if this is you're talking
to your wife if this is the number one
thing we don't want the fact that we
love each other to be messed up by this
number one thing so we've got to work on
this together it's a huge deal I'm
really concerned about it because I care
so much about you and so we've got to do
something together on this money thing
we got to figure this out
and and then let her get involved in why
you get out of debt because getting out
getting out of debt just to get out of
debt is not fun but getting out of debt
so that I have money oh why would I want
money also I can live a good life right
I can have a car and pay cash for it I
can go on vacation and pay cash for it
and but you can't do that if you're in
debt and so then you but she hasn't seen
a real
and to do all of this yet she just heard
you yakking about baby steps if you're
not careful if you're not careful you
don't turn my name into a cuss word I
think it already is yeah we'll see you
problem maybe you start this
conversation with an apology
like I started this whole thing wrong
I've kind of been doing it wrong
but it's but my you need to understand
my heart it's because the number one
caused a divorce and I'm really worried
about that the German they ask you this
your mom and dad fight about money in
front of you I know I know I know there
were money problems but I think they
ever did it in front of you sometime you
remember feeling the stress of money in
your house growing up I don't I just
remember after my mom died my stepdad
found hidden credit card bills that he
didn't know about okay use that story
okay I don't ever want to be there how
about her parents
yeah they could use your baby steps to
you okay but I mean so yeah it's asker
have you seen your mom and dad fight
about money we don't want to be there I
don't beam on stuff that is you don't be
where your parents are where they're
fighting about money because by the way
Josh most people have fights about money
it's the number one thing people fight
about so I mean you know if you bring
that up I mean you get are talking that
way that this is a marriage issue it's a
relationship issue that we deal with
this subject and if you can get her to
go to the Financial Peace University
class with you I will give it to you as
a wedding gift to get you guys started
but do not go to this class by yourself
because you don't need any more weapons
and your belt you've got plenty of
weapons you've been using we need honey
on the bread instead so it's so honey I
got this free class for us to go - I got
this classic guy gave it to me I'm
giving it to you as a gift and that'll
help you get your life started off right
it takes it's one night a week for nine
weeks it should be part of every
pre-marriage counseling plan to go
through this class on how to handle
money and so we're doing this as part of
our pre marriage counseling and we're
you know we're gonna be on the same page
together because I don't want to be like
my stepdad I don't wanna be like your
parents I love them but I don't want to
be in those situations
and with the stress that most people
have I don't want be in that situation